[Musique]
on estime que seulement 10% de notre
cerveau vrai ou faux c'est faux mais
c'est un mythe qui a la vie dure très
dure c'est presque une parole d'évangile
dans la bouche des apôtres du paranormal
parce que ça ouvre la porte à toutes
sortes de capacité et haute eric qui
serait là en dormant dans notre boîte
crânienne un bon gros 90 % de matière
grise qui demanderaient seulement à être
exploité pour nous faire enfin atteindre
notre plein potentiel
en 2014 luc besson a même donné au mythe
une dimension cinématographique avec son
film lucie dans son rôle d russie morgan
freeman a l'air extrêmement crédible je
remercie condamnons 5 on estime que la
plupart des humains n'utilise que 10 %
de leurs capacités cérébrales imaginez
si nous pouvions être 100% ça commence à
devenir intéressant et dans road l'eau
si le personnage principal scarlett
johannson dépasse le seuil des 10% ce
qui lui donne des super pouvoirs
elle apprend le chinois instantanément
elle déplace des voitures par la seule
force de sa pensée et elle change la
couleur de ses cheveux à volonté notre
cerveau fait une machine phénoménal mais
d'où vient l'idée selon laquelle c'est
100 milliards de neurones sont sous
utilisés il ya toutes sortes
d'hypothèses mais c'est pas clair peu
importe d'un point de vue évolutionniste
ce serait une aberration
notre cerveau représente seulement 2% de
la masse du corps mais consomme 20% de
toute son énergie
jamais on aurait développé un organe
aussi énergivore qui fait 90% inutilisés
ce qui est vrai c'est qu'on comprend
probablement beaucoup moins de 10% du
fonctionnement du cerveau humain on
comprend pas tout à fait comment ils
enregistrent l'information pour en faire
des souvenirs comment ces différentes
parties interagissent pour générer ce
qu'on appelle conscience ou les racines
neuronale les plus profondes de notre
comportement de nos émotions
mais les techniques d'imagerie cérébrale
de plus en plus sophistiqués nous révèle
lentement ses secrets et ses techniques
là elle le montre bien y'en a pas de
zone inactivité
on utilise bel et bien 100% notre
cerveau toutes les sommes ne s'active
pas de la même façon en même temps mais
tous s'activent à un moment où l'autre
et tout comme nos connaissances à son
sujet le cerveau va lui aussi continué à
évoluer et tout comme il est aujourd'hui
beaucoup plus performant que celui de
lucy lucy l'australopithèque
qu'utilisait elle aussi 100% de son
modeste cerveau dans quelques millions
d'années qui sait si va pas évoluer au
point de faire pâlir d'envié la dossier
de luc besson
c'est un peu rudimentaire mais vous êtes
sur la bonne voie